hey everybody and welcome to another hd
tutorial and in this video i'll be
walking you through the entire um
basically rocketduck interface
now
i've already done a video about how to
acquire the rocketdocs software you can
probably just click on my name or i'll
try to put that in the description
somehow but um forgive me if it's not
there
so basically what we're going to do here
is go over rocketdoc if you want to see
what's in my dock you can look here now
we have our internet browsers and our
internet related things
we have oh yeah in downloader and
ccleaner
then we have our microsoft office
documents and as well as photoshop
then we have our communications section
which includes email skype ucam which is
the webcam software in google earth and
bluetooth
now we have a few tools which i have cam
studio the camtasia software the
windows 7 calculator
notepad a little ocr which is basically
my scanner converting that to text etc
the sage dictionary
here's my media section you can see i
have separators in between sections we
have windows media center itunes windows
media player and the rhapsody for my
phone
and then we have the stuff that came
with it by standard and i also added a
downloads section so they have my
computer network documents music
pictures this is the standard stuff and
i put utorrent all the way on the right
hand side with the recycling bin and
dock settings now dock settings is the
most important thing basically in the
whole
software section of um
the rocket dock so we're going to go
over here we'll start with the general
tab is this is all the in the languages
that you can choose to have um your doc
and your language in i'm not going to
change anything with that because i
speak english
so you can have it run at startup i have
left that check which means the doc will
automatically come up at your startup
store settings in a portable ini that's
just basically if you want someone else
to log into your computer then their
rocket dock would just be the standard
one but yours when you logged on would
have all your icons
minimize windows to the dock now if i
tick that and i hit okay i just have to
show you what that looks like if i have
a notepad document up here and i
minimize it you'll see it swipes in and
there is my notepad document i click it
and it kind of drags out
and again minimize
it has a little animation that you can
disable if it gets a nine
but um that's basically what minimize
windows to dock memes and if you do have
windows vista then you will get the live
previews so you have a youtube youtube
thing running then that will work
however i have disabled that so they
minimized the trade because actually
like the way they work here in windows
vista
so next we have a running application
instance or indicator so i have a
firefox preloader right now so right now
there's a little black arrow above it
you can see and that is what the uh open
application
instance or indicator actually means so
i have skype on right now i should put
that as do not disturb i have skype
running right now
i have my
email client as well as a screen
recorder etc so that is what that means
um open running application instance
means that if i already have a notepad
document open and i go up here and hit
the notepad button it will bring up the
one that is already open so that's
pretty cool
and lock items is basically so i can't
accidentally drag one out and delete it
you can easily just right click on the
dock and hit
unlock items and then that will simply
unlock all the items and you can drag
them around change the order change the
icon itself etcetera
let's go to icons right now i have it on
high quality because of my computer's i
mean the computer i'm running this on is
a pretty intense gaming machine it's a
laptop but it's very good so i left it
on high quality just to get the best
quality out of my uh my icons i left
them on 100 opacity now what this means
if you see the dock above here this
means that whenever i
i'm looking at them they have full
opacity they're completely opaque over
my desktop but if i were to lower the
opacity
you see they get a little transparent
but i've checked the box that says zoom
opaque so when i actually mouse over it
the one that i'm mousing over is no
longer transparent it's actually opaque
again so that's pretty cool that i can
do that
but i leave them all pretty much on full
opacity so i can see them whenever i
want
the size is basically the size of the
icons very very self-intuitive there
now there's two hover effects there's a
bubble which you see when i go over
these
there is a plateau which kind of just
spreads them out more and doesn't go up
and down vertically as much
and then there is zoom flat which just
completely goes sideways and you can
move the entire rocky dock like this i
think this is the coolest way but i
really don't need it to expand that much
so i don't use that
um so i leave it at zoom bubble you can
also have no zoom which is also that
actually works on mac os 10 you just
have the names pop up
if you're tired of those animations so
i've left it on zoom bubble
next we have the actual mount that it
does zoom and the zoom width that's
pretty much self-explanatory if you
wanted to zoom to be humongous say i go
from 15 to 228 look it just gets
ginormous and you can see the higher
quality of the icons when i actually do
that like that's a not very good icon
that's very pixelated but that's a
really high quality icon right there so
that's pretty good
i leave this down closer to about
20 or no i leave it too close to about
15 pixels which is what i had before
so now let's go to position this is
where it gets kind of interesting a lot
of people like to put their rocket dock
down or you can also choose what monitor
it's on i have unplugged the other
monitor so my laptop's only got one
monitor hooked up
um you can choose the screen position to
be on the bottom okay so it'll be all
the way on the bottom of your screen
almost exactly like mac os 10.
obviously you'll want to have some edge
offset so it's not on top of your
toolbar but a lot of people that i know
actually unlock this
taskbar and drag it to the top
so they have their taskbar on top and
they have their rocket dock on the
bottom
okay
and that's giving it a whole lot more of
a mac os 10 theme especially with the
theme that i've installed on this rocket
dock that's pretty cool but i'm just
going to reverse that because i lift i
pretty much leave it on
on the top you can also put it on the
left or the right if you so desire so
i'm leaving on the top edge offset is
basically how far from the edge it is
you can have it halfway down your screen
you could have it right flush with the
edge so i leave mine flush
and also centering i leave mine dead in
the center you can make it further to
the left if you have the sidebar maybe
or further to the right
now let's go to
style
style i did a previous video on it so
i'm not going to talk too much about it
but basically you can install and
download and get more by hitting this
button a whole bunch of themes and also
change the fonts and the opacity of the
fonts when you mouse over one of those
icons so that's pretty cool
next is the behavior button this is
pretty much the last um
the last important one if you actually
click on an icon like in mac os 10 it'll
bounce for a second so look if i click
on camstudio
actually no i can't do it now so if i
hit okay and i click on camstudio it'll
bounce for a second and you can see
that that's the kind of attention that
it gets when it when you uh when you
actually click on it so if i click on my
computer it bounces once or twice then
opens it up so that's pretty cool
if i go back into settings i can
actually disable that because again that
just takes a tiny bit more cpu and i'd
rather not the uber icon effects i have
not found that to work very well but if
i do try it let's see
i do try it no it doesn't work it just
it kind of makes it a little
a little uh explosion effect when you
click on the icon it's not that great
but
so i just leave it at none
and also you can set it to auto hide now
here's a cool thing a lot of people do
if i hit okay
the dock is just gone right but whenever
i mouse over close to the top of the
screen it comes back and i can choose
whatever i want from here then when i
leave it it hides back again
so that's pretty cool feature if you
really like a really clean desktop you
may have noticed i have absolutely no
icons on my whole desktop so that is uh
that's why i use a rocket dock in the
first place so you can also choose how
long it takes to pop up
you can choose the delay how long it
takes to pop up etc so i left unchecked
auto hide and that is basically it you
can reset the all the defaults at any
time by just pressing that default
button and also you can see this is
version 1.3.5 copyright punk software so
you can update it just by hitting that
one simple button if you have any
problems with it you can hit the forums
button
and that is basically it so i hope you
enjoyed this tutorial a little
walkthrough of the menus and also uh
there's this little thing where you can
right click i didn't show you yet you
can hit the unlock items button so i can
remove an icon and then it would just
disappear where i would um drag it back
in wherever i want to put it so that's
pretty interesting feature i like to
show you guys um and mac on the uh the
rocket dock
and hopefully i can get back to you guys
with more tutorials if you have any
requests for any tutorial at all i will
handle it as best as i can all i got to
do is subscribe and send me a personal
message and i'll get to it as soon as i
can thanks for watching guys peace